bring it please I'm begging you right
here on the [__] chin do it do it do
it now
begging you
beware of who you come at in this fear
beware oh if you don't know what's
happening right now this guy is called
The Godfather of the red pill he wrote a
book
um that a lot of people think is really
important some of you other people might
know him as Tim Poole's father and he's
upset that we talked about Donovan sharp
being a fraud is he Temple of our father
not are they just for some reason are
both grown men who wear beanies every
day
I don't know I think for temple it's
more acceptable because like he's in his
20s but like you're you're a 50 year old
man married wearing beanies every day
maybe he's cold
I understand the sentiment yeah marriage
is a lonely life
[Music]
it's all right it's just something about
a dude who's like been married for 25
years I'll be like let me tell you about
dating I'm gonna shut your old ass up
you ain't been dating forever you you a
lot [__] were using uh Morse
code to get at each other
typewriters I and if I use typewriters
yeah
he used right he got 15 years on you
yeah yeah okay but let me explain one
other thing to you Auburn preach before
you start like mouthing off with
[__] like that especially with
people that I know and again I'm not
defending uh Donovan that's yeah that's
his house he can go do you you want he's
oh he's defending him go talk to Donovan
that's on him did he do it well yeah
clearly he's talked to it he's talked
about it he's right he took he's uh he
took the hit for it way back when
Anthony came at him back in 2020 that
ABBA and preach clearly didn't know
anything about because they wouldn't
have come up with this this lame
contrived video
and they even admit in the video that
they got the information from from
Anthony
could it be because he's paying you to
do these attack piece videos I can't
wait for the one on me shills of Anthony
Johnson but you're happy to take that
[__] money and run with it it's a
paid it's a product placement
I think people looked yeah he said we're
paid by it first off I didn't even know
his name was Anthony Johnson I just know
him as the guy from 21 Studios I don't
know much about him okay I don't know
who's about him but if you think we get
paid to cover anybody you are bugging
you can't prove something that did not
happen that's my point so you got to
bring the proof you can't just make that
kind of allegation but the whole rant is
irrational but whatever I'm not I'm not
here defending Donovan proceeds to try
to defend down anybody but hey wait wait
with bogus allegations yeah and I think
he put a price on how much we were paid
hey but don't we get mad at ladies when
they make false allegations that's fair
those are some very serious allegations
that's why we need this level of
accuracy that's why we need to see we
need to speak in terms in in ways that
are are that leave no room for error
it turns out that even rational males or
red pill dweebs right they turn into
making up false allegations about people
right when they don't like them fast
they just make it up
look at this he said we can't pay for it
funny how they talk about oh they these
[__] and then come to find out you
the [__]
anyway let's listen to Temple's dad tell
me who's left I can't please do it again
I would love to to recover this because
you do that I'll be happy to uh release
all of the screen caps I have of you
cyber stalking my daughter
bring it please I'm begging you right
here on the [__] chin do it do it do
it now
begging you
oh this is weird watching a grown man
say come for me come after me I'm
waiting for it like calm down I don't
care about your stuff I don't care about
your content I think you're another one
of them red pill goofballs from what I
can see right now
look and also I think it's interesting
people call things hit piece when they
just don't like the truth being exposed
about them what did we say in there
that's a lie according to you we didn't
make up any lies so how is it a hit
piece go talk to Donovan that's on him
did he do it yeah clearly he doesn't
know what a hit piece is that's when you
bring out false information to
misrepresent somebody but that's who he
is that's his videos we didn't take
things out of context so if you want to
make the claim and the false allegation
that's a hit piece you have to provide
the evidence but again red pill dudes
much like the women they love to
criticize and the bimbos that they meet
in Miami are very emotional and love to
make false allegations that they can't
prove themselves I've been preach you
got you are treading on thin [__]
eyes my friend because when Donovan does
his response video to you you can expect
that he's gonna quote or he's going to
bring up he's going to probably he's
going to bring up the video of you
and your milking video with uh Shan
booty okay
okay I guess this is that
the ammunition these guys think they
have against me that I like getting my
ass ate every now and then sure yeah oh
I don't really care what you guys think
if I haven't attracted a woman who wants
to do that and I enjoy it then we can do
it I don't give a [__] is that is that
you see how Juvenile and irrational
these masculine leaders get whenever you
slightly po I didn't even pause this
dude I poke the next man pause because
poke is kind of sucks but I poke is the
next man
okay and this guy had a reaction like
if I understand yeah
then clearly you're saying oh well wait
until he replies and he does it
he made
false assumption about my wife and drag
the whole person that has nothing to do
romantically with me
and drag that person on the five hour
live
preach your wife is a bad
I'm gonna say that one more time preach
your wife is a fat and now you're mad
because we expose some [__] that he said
that is true but but you you cannot
see what the [__] he did but you like
man yeah he did whatever he did whatever
you go you go over that when the person
went on the web and slender a person
that had nothing to do with anything
Hey listen how does that work in your
how are you calling yourself rational
and that is the situation and you're
like nah and you're defending it and
you're defending it how bro by today's
sponsor t.h Henley's coming in to save
the day he don't know what to do and
it's a bit overwhelming I understand
that I would suggest you to buy the
level one box which comes with all the
basics a daily face watch which gets rid
of all the dirt and Grime on your face
they got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and they're going to be able to give
you all the instruction in order for you
to have a good skin care for you to be
looking all Flawless yeah because that's
your money maker that's the first thing
that people see when they see you your
face that's right and you got to take
care of it if you click on the link
below you will not only save 30 off your
first box but you will also receive a
gift get it it's uncomplicated skin care
routine for men that's what I use look
at this Flawless that shit's nice rub
out that face so you can actually start
looking fresh
beware of who you come at in this sphere
beware and it's not and you better you
better be clean you better have a
[__] clean nose before you do that
because I know damn well you took money
I know damn well why you like there's no
earthly reason for you to actually just
out of the blue do a hit piece on
Donovan sharp there's no reason
not even you can't even explain you
can't even explain that away well we
wanted to get clicks no no you didn't we
we know you're full of [__] you
you idiot I thought something way better
was gonna come out
I got nothing else you idiots Hey listen
he said you had no reason uh [__] this
man did a whole live stream where he was
calling his supposed wife a whole bunch
of different names and then not only
that he was talking about the wrong
person one of our friends and so he was
bringing her to the public eye and
basically doxed her for everyone else to
see for no reason okay
how are you going to call yourself the
rational male and give this [__]
schizo-level defense of your good friend
I'll easily defend Donovan how can a man
be a crook when his work actually saves
lives more than what his haters ever
have to say you know what tell these
[__] to go to hell yeah an album
preach are the just to tell to go to
hell because they are shills
openly blatantly obviously they got [__]
all over their face shills of Anthony
Johnson because all that stuff has been
out for ages guys you're not revealing
anything new and you look like idiots
for doing it in fact you look worse than
idiots you look like shills you look
like it was fast money
you don't even know who he is you
probably have no earthly you know who I
am you know he is you don't know who
anybody in the sphere is whatsoever but
you're happy to take that [__] money
and run with it it's okay it's a product
placement it's like getting that email
in your emails hey we really love your
channel we'd love for you to promote our
new game uh Warriors of chaos for
Seventeen hundred dollars for a 30
second spot that's you and except that's
your whole [__] show no uh let's see
uh was it Excel plus VPN 1700 for a 30
second plug that's [__] you that's
you and you know in this case it just
happened to be oh hey can you do about a
20 minute hit piece on on uh Don and
sharp I'll give you 1200 bucks
are you guys that hard up for money
because I'll give you 1200 bucks to go
and do it I'll give you 1300 to go do a
hit piece on [__] Anthony Johnson you
probably take the money too I'm not
gonna lie yo anybody wanna pay me 20
grand to do hippies on this dude I'll do
three of them
y'all give me 20 grand I'll do three
I'll do whatever Hey listen apparently
I'm paid the bot for so I might as well
make some money so if y'all got 20 G's I
already don't like this dude so I'll be
I'll take 20 G's to do it Hey listen you
know what we're gonna do a fundraiser at
the bottom actually I'm gonna put a I'm
gonna do a go for me yo [__] it yo [__]
it we're gonna do a GoFundMe if we raise
20 G's I'm gonna do a hippies on this
guy 100 bucks I go and do them I'll give
you 1300 to go do a hit piece on [__]
Anthony Johnson you probably take the
money too certainly you gotta pay us way
more than that listen we're not one of
them winning fools you gotta pay a lot
you think product placement is 1300 on
our Channel bro you gotta up them
numbers to a little broke ass beanie
come on bro we better than you [__]
I'm just playing I'm sorry I always want
to do that one time
yeah we got more money
I like I like broke ass beanie
listen bro I can't take wait I can't
take a man in his 50s wearing a beanie
it's like it's like seeing a a woman in
her 60s wearing baby fat it's like your
[__] Days Are Over no but broke ass
Genie sorry the baby fat and the horse
that's always a broke ass beanie okay
listen that's a fire knife broke ass
beanie hobo and Screech never learned
their lesson no they don't
like a bad [__] case at genital warts
keep coming back I felt oddly personal I
like you're experiencing that right now
yeah what's wrong like a bad case of
herpes on your anus
oh okay I think you know what I'm gonna
give a shout out to a lot of the folks
in the red pill Community because
they're not having it they say nah that
dude's a fraud and roll you look stupid
for you know what let me give a shout
out to the red pill I never do this but
the fan base is not nearly as
manipulated and easily like maybe they
feel informed as people make them out to
be you know they coming from yeah listen
Hey listen people were like I just
realized the red pill is a giant joke
even this guy okay yeah people are
noticing it
but I thought you know what to be fair I
don't think it's the entire red pill
it's just that the goofballs are a
really goofball I agree I do like some
of them I don't think it's the whole red
pill Community that's like that and I
think
I think that most guys in the red pill
committee you're able to have a sit down
with there with them
you're able to have a sit down with them
and they're not has uh as um
delusional as that they're not as goof
goofy but not as extreme and even them
they're like that's not what it is yeah
so
I'm not gonna be ready to to I'm you
know what I'm gonna take back I'm gonna
take back a couple of things I said
about the red pill I'm not ready to put
all of them in the same categories just
that the goofballs are allowed as [__]
because there's a lot of them yeah
they're compensating for a lot of things
but I will say a lot of them do work
with the goofballs and the frauds yeah
and they know that they're knowing frogs
so that's a little sus but anyways low
at everyone calling Romo Rolo an
emotional like it's an own
when can men be passionate in expressing
their anger
oh okay because he's saying that he's
passionate he's not he okay oh he's not
being emotional he's being passionate oh
my God the amount of cope that you have
to write something this [__]
loser-ish men can be passionate that
doesn't mean it's a bad thing okay so
when women expressed any kind of
volatility all of a sudden it's they're
hysterical they're emotional when men do
it they're being Passionate big dog in
the building come on guys come on guys
a little bit honest with yourselves call
it like call a spade a spade
I think that pretty much covers it I
think this dude's a goofball and it's
just fascinating watching dudes call
themselves rational males and all this
other stuff giving the most
nonsensical arguments
uh anything you want to say about this
topic oh no I think that's it from us I
uh
I enjoyed that
I enjoyed that like I said gofundme's in
the bottom 20K I'm serious I'm dead ass
if y'all get to 20K at 100 I'll do it
that's how much it gonna cost for this
guy that's a discount if nobody charged
seven times that amount but for this guy
I'll do for 20K
and I don't know Anthony Johnson I pray
that's your name you get out give me
everything
see I told you guys
but I will take that money I will take
that money